yeah yeah come on come on come on
[Music]
okay hi what's your name Gabriella
Gabrielle Gabrielle and um
are would you consider yourself a
feminist no I'm surprised I've had so
many people come up and say they aren't
feminists why do you think that is
I don't know maybe they don't want to
look bad because if you say that you're
not a feminist then you're bad and so
when I went out to do interviews I
really was encouraged by how many people
actually agreed with me and didn't
believe in feminism or identify as a
feminist when I originally went out I
thought that everyone was gonna Just
Disagree and be mad but it was really
cool to see that you know maybe not all
Western women are lost
and uh but I don't think I just don't
want to be associated with the word it
doesn't mean that I don't identify with
some of the things that feminists say I
just think there's a lot of like uh
Prejudice about feminism in general
because of
yeah as you said like sometimes they get
very offended or like the attitude I
just don't like it what do you think
feminism is fighting for in 2022
I mean they advocate for equality but
sometimes they
it's not really a quality is it it's
just it's not very balanced sometimes so
even some things that you were saying
like I don't like that woman wants so
many rights but like a few things that
are considered normal in society like
the man has to pay for dinner or the man
has to ask out or the man has to propose
to a woman why does it have to be like
this like I I don't agree with it I
think that if you really want equality
you should have equality in every field
even if it's not convenient for you you
know
yeah and what um
what do you think about like the Johnny
Depp and Amber Heard situation
um do you feel like that was the fault
of feminism
I think Ember heard definitely used
feminism in a bad way like for herself
and people at first sided with her only
because she was a woman so they uh they
assumed that she was right and because
the man is always a bad one who's
beating up woman and some people don't
realize that actually it can be the
other way around and thank God that like
uh Johnny actually won the the try on
and it shows that you know uh the
justice system is right and they see
through you know people's lives and
things like that yeah yeah so I agree
um why don't you think we see women
marching the street because for men that
aren't led into bars for free
because they don't care it's not their
problem is it right
yeah I want equality don't they they
want equality for that like they want
the same things as men but they don't
care what men don't have and they have
right like what you said like when men
have privilege sometimes because of
their looks
um
they get hired in some places instead of
men maybe if there's a uh if there's a
man in charge they'll get hired for
their looks and I cannot say that I'm
not privileged because of my looks
obviously I know I just try to not use
it in my advantage you know I just try
to be myself and you know use my
intelligence or something else as a you
know tool let's say okay where are you
from London no where are you from Italy
okay I I find that um
the more like like Eastern I guess in
Europe they don't really agree with
feminism as much would you feel like
that's true
I mean I don't know I guess it's not
such a big issue like we're not so
radical about it like obviously we want
to be equal but we are not uh marching
down the streets or or making a huge
problem about it uh if a man
I don't know it has more rights than us
like we just try to fight for it and uh
like even in our private lives you know
do you feel like equality is possible
with anyone like even me and you were
both we're both women right but me and
you like we're gonna be unequal in
different things so when when people say
equality I never know what they're
talking about
yeah because I guess it there's always a
third party that kind of sets the
standards right for equality so
I guess equality just means like same
chances and possibility for everyone but
I don't like to I don't even like the
word equality I think we were talking
about this with some friends I think
um equality is never the right word
because people come from different
backgrounds different like even
economical situations so we don't have
the same possibilities so it's almost
like equality of opportunity would be
better than just
I don't remember the exact word we use
not equality we use like inclusion or
something like that yeah okay well thank
you so much I appreciate it do you have
any socials you want to plug uh yes my
Instagram it's at Gabby underscore dmua
I'm a makeup artist thank you so much I
appreciate it I'm Pearl nice to meet you
um would you identify as a feminist I
would say that I will I do yes okay so
what do you think we need feminism for
in 2022
um so this girl demanded that she see
this video the edits before I post it
um so this is just me letting you know
that no
um you decided to sit down and get
recorded you don't get to see what I do
with the footage well in 2022 I think we
need feminism for the equality of all
genders and all Sexes and that's that
really so what like like what specific
policy are we fighting for
equality of all Sexes and the fact that
men have certain privileges that of
course women don't we don't have the
privilege of walking in the middle of
the night and not being scared that
someone's going to attack us and we're
fighting for equality in those times and
beyond that as well in terms of you know
in the legal World in terms of Education
in terms of jobs there's so many things
with that so to start men are more
likely to be victims of a violent crime
than women
so um if like and I don't really know
what policy we'd be fighting for because
I think across the board like I I say
grape on YouTube I can't say that
I can't say I can't say rap YouTube so
I'm gonna say great okay like grape is
illegal murder is legal so all violence
is illegal so I just don't know what
policy we're fighting for because if you
just tell
bad guys don't don't grape or don't kill
like they're not gonna stop but like
marches aren't going to fix that it's
just law enforcement yeah I agree I I'm
an aspiring virus so I know that more
than anything it is the legal side of
things that
do need to be putting Force more I guess
boldly and solidly to in order for us to
actually achieve equality it's not a
thing of oh what is the one policy
that's going to make this work and
that's going to that what we're fighting
for there's so many things that feminism
is fighting for and you can't sort of
box that into a certain thing and say oh
what is the one policy you're fighting
for I disagree with that it's not it's
not it's not one policy because to me we
are equal yeah like to me in 2022 I
don't think we need feminism because I
don't think there's anything left to
fight for
well I would disagree with that and I
think I don't know where the
conversation would go from now other
than to say that there are so many
things